i thought i'd talk to you about
factorials let me give an example so we
know what we're talking about 3
factorial is just a product
of 1 times 2 times 3. now of course i
didn't need to write the 1 because 1
times whatever comes after is still just
whatever comes after but this is 6.
everybody probably remembers the
factorial in general is the product of
all of the integers between 1 and
whatever number you write last so the
second example i'm going to skip 4 and
go straight to 5 factorial which is 1
times 2
times 3 times 4
times 5 and that after you multiply it
all out is actually 120. probably a lot
of us have encountered the factorial and
had to figure out what is you know seven
factorial what is eight factorial and
what you you know you remember what you
do you you figure out what the previous
factorial is and multiply by the next
number or you just have to do a whole
bunch of multiplications
which is let's face it not not
everybody's favorite thing to do what i
want to tell you about actually is not
just the factorial but
i want to tell you about a great
approximation
maybe you can think of it as a function
a machine something that simplifies the
pr the description of the factorial
function
at a at a cost and the cost is sort of
accuracy it goes by the name of
sterling's approximation and so in order
to talk about sterling's approximation i
have to introduce a letter which will be
a large number so i'm going to use
capital n and say capital n factorial
that is now if n is 5 that is the number
120 if n is 3 that is the number 6. so i
want to ask how does this factorial
function how does it behave if n gets
larger and larger and larger okay i mean
just as an example you could imagine
asking what's a hundred factorial and
then you're multiplying a hundred times
well so 2 times 3 times 4 times 5 all
the way up to 100 it's probably an
enormous number well here's an
approximation that will will
you know allow you to understand a lot
about the factorial function that little
symbol means approximately equal to and
then it is n to the power n times e to
the negative n times the square root of
n times the square root of 2 pi so i
didn't write equals and i want to spend
a little bit time explaining what this
what i mean by this little symbol here
because it's really an approximation of
n factorial it's not exactly equal to
the factorial but it's an approximation
before i even tell you in what sense is
an approximation it's it's fun to ask
which one of these is easier to work
with
because professor you said a moment ago
that you were going to show me a
simplification but at first glance that
doesn't look like a simplification to me
that looks like a right old mess
compared to just
10 times 11 times 12 times 13. but you
tell me this is simpler yeah so that's a
that's a fantastic point and it doesn't
look like it's simpler but it actually
is so the the amount of computations you
need to compute a very large number
factorial like 100 factorial is actually
much larger than the number of
computations that you would need on the
computer to evaluate the right hand side
when n is a hundred and in that sense it
really is a simplification okay so it's
like it's a bit of a hack here it's a
bit of a shortcut but but you don't get
it exactly right that's exactly right so
this is what we mean when we say it's an
approximation instead of saying do these
two things get closer and closer to each
other as n grows i want to consider the
ratio so i have n factorial and i form a
fraction where the numerator is n
factorial and the denominator is
this approximation sterling's
approximation is an approximation in the
sense that
as i get larger and larger values of n
this ratio gets closer and closer to one
what i've just described is actually a
concept called a limit and that you know
you learn about it basically in a
precalculus course or a calculus course
and so i should write out more precisely
i mean
limit as n goes to infinity and now i'm
going to rewrite that whole ratio n
factorial over n to the n e to the
negative n square root of n square root
of 2 pi
equals 1. so so that is the mathematical
version of this arrow
and just means as n
gets larger and larger and larger this
quantity gets closer and closer and
closer to the number one
so so as we start
factorializing if that's the word bigger
and bigger numbers
this sterling approximation becomes more
useful
exactly yeah that's that's exactly right
here's a funny fact for very large
numbers the two values n factorial
itself and the approximation they
actually don't get closer to each other
in in sort of magnitude it's just their
ratio that gets close to one and it
seems funny that can happen without
these two numbers actually
getting close to each other so some
examples are useful to see what i'm
talking about there so where are we
going to start well let's start with a
small number like uh 5 factorial so we
already know that it's 120 what do we
get if we uh if we plug 5 into this
crazy formula right here 5 to the fifth
power e to the negative 5
times the square root of 5 times the
square root of 2 pi i i did that
offline and here's what you get 118
0.019
that's pretty close
you think that's close or not
well let's be honest it's off by almost
2. that's probably that doesn't seem so
close right
but remember that
that really what i should be checking to
to check closeness is is does the ratio
get close to 1. so if i compute the
ratio of 120 over 118
and
.019 and use a calculator offline
that
actually is 1.01
six
uh seven eight
should we go smaller or bigger we're
gonna go bigger let's go bigger okay so
um
what's a p what's a good number
uh 100
hundred is a great choice
let's see i think i know that one
actually i don't and it would probably
run out of ink before i finish writing
it so what can i tell you about the 100
factorial well it's enormous it has a
158 digits
so i probably could fit it on this paper
but but maybe it's not too illuminating
to write out a 158 digit number that's
at the same time maybe it is
illuminating and hopefully you can see
it on the screen right now and if i now
use the approximation instead of writing
out 158 digits
if i use the approximation here is the
first interesting statement i can make
the approximation captures the first two
digits correctly that feels like a
failure to me there are so many wrong
digits that seems like a bad
approximation but you're telling me
that's a good approximation yeah right
it sounds funny but the the beautiful
fact is it captures the size correctly
the magnitude of the number is also
correct consider the ratio 100 factorial
over the approximation i'll just write
down the word approximation then it
turns out that is 1.00083
and so the you know the ratio of the two
is almost one up to
eight parts in ten thousand so in that
sense it's actually capturing the right
size and the first digits so even though
five factorial was out by only two and
this new one you've given me is out by
zillions it's actually closer yeah it's
it's it's really a fact that the
approximation that the
brutal distance between the two things
the actual 100 factorial and the
approximation is is very large but
the the relative size is is nailing the
relative size
uh one more example
you go you choose a number this time so
how about 2 000 so that is a number that
has 5
7 hundred and thirty some digits
that's a big number that wouldn't fit on
this piece of paper
and if i were to compute the
approximation let me say it like this if
i if i compute the ratio using
sterling's approximation it is one point
zero zero zero zero
four
at a hundred factorial the approximation
the ratio gave one point zero zero zero
eight three eight parts in ten thousand
this one gives four parts in a hundred
thousand the approximation captures five
almost five digits of two thousand
factorial but mind you it is a number
which has five thousand seven hundred
and some digits as we approach the limit
you're telling me this ratio is getting
closer and closer to one
but will the actual difference between
the two numbers also close at any time
or will that just continue to balloon
yeah the actual distance between them
will continue to balloon absolutely
grows in fact grows very very fast
but the ratio still goes to one
it seems counterintuitive at first
thought doesn't it
yeah so um so another question that
people ask about often is uh well this
is a crazy formula on the left hand side
you you are just multiplying together
integers
and the asymptotic description the
approximate description on the right
hand side it's it's got some interesting
things it's got the number e euler's
constant it comes from calculus it's got
root 2 pi which has a pi in the middle
of it you know where does this formula
come from and how do these crazy
constants that come from some other
parts of mathematics how do they appear
in this
i don't want to give you a complete
answer for that but there is a beautiful
formula which provides a fantastic
explanation there's a way to represent
any integer factorial as an integral
from 0 to infinity of x to the n
times e to the negative x dx now this is
something which if you have had a course
in calculus you would see this and say
oh i bet i can evaluate that think of it
as a beautiful way to represent n
factorial and so some folks would say n
factorial is actually represented as an
integral and once you have an integral
you can begin to play all kinds of
tricks
and there's a five step process to to
compute this approximation step five
at the very end out pops the square root
of two pi
who uses sterling's formula
so
uh many many scientists use sterling's
formula so uh people in in mathematics
in the fields of combinatorics it's it's
uh it's their bread and butter people in
mathematical physics who study
statistical physics they use this this
approximation all of the time
essentially every area of mathematics in
which there's large numbers appearing
the approximation becomes very useful
many areas of physics they calculations
are done on the back of envelopes and
those calculations always involve this
approximation because it simplifies
things
are they using it to to save time or
because it's a better thing to use it's
a better thing to use and it does save
time
but it's really a a machine that will
simplify calculations when you're
interested in sort of behavior as number
of
unknowns grows to infinity or number of
particles in a system goes to infinity
it's it's a simplifying machine in those
situations of course for smaller numbers
it may not be so useful but once you
have a large
number floating around in your you need
the factorial of that large number this
is a
approximation that's very useful you
take the best computer you can find and
you ask how large a value of n can i
plug in and get an exact answer and how
large can i take this formula and use
the same computer to evaluate this
formula and the answer is
the approximation can be evaluated for
much much larger values of the integer n
than the exact formula n factorial
because it just takes so long to compute
how easily in my head now that's equal
to 120. so these numbers increase quite
quickly so it's fun just to work out
factorial 20 and i can do that by
continuing this process but it's much
easier to get out my pocket calculator
so let's do 20 so there's 20 going in